Jennifer Lopez and Marc Anthony might  just be Hollywood's friendliest exes  I think you're the most glamorous couple  the former couple split in 2011 but that  doesn't mean there's any bad blood case  in point this adorable snapchat video  JLo shared on Tuesday the pop star  captioned the hilarious post studio  shenanigans JLo is currently working  with marks company Magnes media on her  upcoming Spanish album her first  entirely spanish record in ten years all  about family it's hardly the first time  we've seen the former flames reunites in  August the former American Idol judge  surprised her ex on stage in New York to  sing their duet no my honest  that same month mark returned the favor  by hitting up J Lo's all I have  residency show in Las Vegas and adorable  JLo even gave Marc a shout-out on stage